ich glaube ich entscheide mich doch für
den betrieb auf der rechten seite aber
ist luca und ich hasse schule wie denke
ich jedes normale kennt allerdings
sollte man denn noch immer in der schule
aufpassen weil es die zukunft von einem
selbst m sehr sehr drüber einfluss von
da habe ich mir gedacht machen wir heute
mal einen grundschul test www willy
wonka balls habe ich voll bock auf
charlie und die schokoladenfabrik mit
unserem grundschuld test könnt ihr
nämlich überprüfen wie viel ihr noch aus
euren ersten unterrichtsstunden behalten
habt wahrscheinlich gar nichts
jedenfalls sagen wir euch welche
schulempfehlung ihr jetzt so ganz ohne
vorbereitung bekommen würde
krass
der sie bissen
ich finde also heute heraus welche
schulempfehlungen ich mit meinem
jetzigen wissensstand bekommen würde
also hauptschule realschule oder
gymnasium beginnen wir mit deutsch und
kommen direkt zur ersten aufgabe
bestimme in dem folgenden platz jeweils
das subjekt das verb und das objekt oder
solches lautet susi ließ einen
spannenden roman
ist mich vor
jeder der nicht jeden tag zehntausende
auf den kopf fällt kann was beantworten
einen ist das subjekt roman ist das verb
und susi ist das objekt reicht nicht
nein also susi ist das subjekt ließ ist
das verb und das objekt ist natürlich
der roman das hier ist noch das adjektiv
richtig hallo susi ist in diesem satz
das subjekten liest also lesen ja ein
wert der roman ist in diesem fall das
objekt objekt objekt im sommer objekt
genommen heißt es objekt oder objekt im
deutschunterricht weiter geht's mit
aufgabe 2 wie viele silben hat das board
zimmerdecke und wie werden sie getrennt
sie werde die trennung ist natürlich zu
mehr direkt zwischen dem sieg also 4
es ist bestimmt viel dicker
nein man kann nicht zwischen c- und
kartrennen vor dem 10
ich sag vor dem zimmerdecke hat vier
silben und es hing mehr den 1 ich komme
fast bei der zweiten aufgabe vergab
welches dieser drei haas ist das
schreibschrift h
da
oder
real coach falls jemand von euch noch in
der grundschule ist von meinen
zuschauern lernt man überhaupt noch
schreibschrift also hier ist noch von l
mit drin das kann es nicht sein und das
hier ist keine richtige schreibschrift
also dass hier im moment
oder es ist doch dass hier
ich kannte ich tatsächlich sagen ich
glaube ich entscheide mich doch für das
in dem betrieb auf der rechten seite
natürlich einmal nur dumm da kommen wir
jetzt zu mathematik acht tafeln wie viel
kilogramm sind 4500 tonnen
4,5 millionen
oder eine tonne sind 1000 kilogramm
tausender 30 also 30 dahinter sind 4,5
millionen lösen wir auf es sind genau
4.500.000 drei von vier ich kann nicht
aufgabe nummer zwei es geht um spiegel
achsen welche dieser drei linien ist
hier die spiegel achse
die rote
die die schwarze doch die rote klar
natürlich die rote die rote achse ist
die spiegel achse du hast eine minute
zeit um diese rechnung zu lösen ob er es
nicht innerhalb der angegebenen zeit
schafft erhältst du keinen punkt okay es
ist 685 plus 264 +27 okay ich habe jetzt
eine minute zeit also als erstes mal 685
264 940 949 plus 720 969 976
ja
die spulen mal ein bisschen vor hier bis
fast am ende ist 976 ist meine antwort
ich habe jetzt gerade im kopf gerechnet
ohne taschenrechner oder irgendwas ich
glaube das hatte man in der grundschule
auf die richtige antwort ist 906 und
bruder
das war es auch schon mit mathematik
punkte hast du jetzt ich hab dir deine
punktzahl für die auflösung am ende ich
habe fünf von sechs er ich muss jetzt
alles richtig haben uns ist es echt
peinlich dass sie hoch zu laden als
nächstes haben wir drei fragen aus dem
fach sachkunde beginnen wir mit der
ersten aufgabe wie heißt dieses
bundesland land was ist die hauptstadt
des gesuchten bundes landes und die
hauptstadt
alter leck mich am fingernägel ich also
mit erdkunde kann es mir echt jagen
das ist berlin das es brandenburg dass
sie es niedersachsen hamburg bremen und
das ist schleswig holstein
das weiß ich weil jude daherkommt aber
dass
ich hab ja es ist mecklenburg vorpommern
oder ist mecklenburg vorpommern
wie das baden württemberg und nadal ist
dass mecklenburg vorpommern die
hauptstadt
kein plan die sache es ich will jetzt
auch nicht schießen und irgendwie mit
dem handy nachgucken oder irgendwas weil
ich will selbst wissen ich will selbst
wissen ob ich das weiß also kinos die
hauptstadt von schleswig holstein
hamburg von hamburg berlin von berlin
halt uns hier
h
lübeck
lübeck überhaupt hier das bundesland ist
mecklenburg vorpommern die hauptstadt
von mecklenburg vorpommern ist schweden
wäre ich nie draufgekommen schwerin
alter der einwohner haben die denn ein
paar sekunden später war ich habe gar
nachgeguckt schwerin hat nicht mal
100.000 einwohner
überlegt euch mal köln hat eine million
und ist nicht mehr hauptstadt von
nordrhein westfalen nur wenn du sowohl
den namen des bundeslandes wie auch den
namen der stadt wusstest erhältst du
jetzt den punkt kommen
er gibt jedoch im punkt warum zeigt eine
kompassnadel nach norden
wegen dem grab
aktionsfeld oder
weil
ach du heilige kirche freuen ich mache
mir glaube ich komplett zum affen in
diesem video und kommerz auflösung der
nordpol ist magnetisch
[Musik]
ich kann das mit hochladen und die
letzte frage wer war der erste mensch
auf dem mond armstrong
das weiß jedes kind neil armstrong war
der erste mensch auf dem mond neil
armstrong punkt für dich falls du es
wusste
und das war es auch schon mit sachkunde
okay bekommen jetzt zum letzten fach da
gibt es auch wieder drei aufgaben ich
glaube ich muss alle drei richtig haben
damit ich gymnasium schaffe und wir
kommen auch schon zum letzten fach und
zwar englisch die helfer englisch obst
auf englisch schreiben müsste glaube ich
phr der englische art für eine birne ist
per weitergeht herr o mein gott ich
dachte was heißt hier mein gott der dich
ja immer zum affen gemacht gibt auf
englisch die zeit an die auf dieser uhr
angezeigt wird beachte aber dass du die
zeit als halb- oder viertel angeben
sollst und nicht einfach nur die zahlen
übersetzt
ok
entsetzt zeigte steht titel fand nicht
immer so easy also das ist hp und
microsoft pause das könnt ihr euch auch
ganz einfach merken einfach wenn der
zeiger ihr vor ist es ist einfach blöd
past three und wenn er danach es nach
der hälfte ist das blatt vor die hier
gezeigte uhrzeit ist halb vier auf
englisch sagt man extra okay letzte
frage wird jetzt wahrscheinlich
schwierig muss ich richtig beantworten
und die letzte aufgabe vervollständige
diesen satz mama das ist bis mai
my mother's sitzt und meine tante
von meiner mutter ist meine tante und
hand auf englisch heißt an die richtige
antwort ist und also die tante wenn du
das wusste es dann kannst du dir nun
deinen letzten punkt geben das war es
auch schon mit unserem test und wir
kommen zur auflösung her ich bin
gespannt also ich habe zwei sachen
falsch mecklenburg vorpommern hatte ich
falsch
oh mein gott
ich habe drei sache
mecklenburg vorpommern kompassnadel
das schreibschrift hake ich hoffe ich
schaffe es mit neun von zwölf punkten
noch aufs gymnasium wenn du mindestens
fünf punkte hast würdest du eine
realschulempfehlung bekommen ist eine
punktzahl unter 5 erhältst du eine
empfehlung für die hauptschule wenn du
es geschafft haben solltest 9 punkte
oder sogar noch mehr zu bekommen würdest
du höchstwahrscheinlich die empfehlung
fürs genehmigungen erhalten doch ich
hab's geschafft was man natürlich noch
dazu sagen das ist dass man diesen test
hier auf keinen fall ernst nehmen sollte
gerade bei mir ist es jetzt so ich habe
gehofft dass nicht mehr als die hälfte
schaffen und ich habe zum beispiel auch
nie gelernt dass schwerin die hauptstadt
von mecklenburg vorpommern ist also habe
ich nie in der grundschule gelernt ich
habe euch das video und in der
beschreibung verlegen falls sie nicht
erst selber machen möchte
macht ja keinen sinn weil jetzt habt ihr
euch ein video angeguckt und jetzt kennt
er die antworten wenn euch dieses video
allerdings gefallen hat dann das gerne
mal einen daumen hoch da soll ich so was
ich denn schnell noch mal machen mit
anderen grundschule test oder mit
anderen keine ahnung was für tests
vielleicht aus irgendwelchen bestimmten
klassen oder irgendwie so oder bestimmte
fächer vor gerne und in die kommentare
abonniert main kanal aktiviert die
glocke und jetzt kommts auto
[Musik]